[Music]
in a moment I'll point you to a separate
website hosting a short sequence of what
we're calling explorable videos it was
done in collaboration with Ben eater who
some of you may know is that guy who
runs the excellent computer engineering
Channel and if you don't know who he is
viewers of this channel would certainly
enjoy the content of his so do check it
out this collaboration was something a
little different though for both of us
and all of the web development that made
these explorable videos possible is
completely thanks to Ben I don't want to
say too much about it here it's really
something you have to experience for
yourself certainly one of the coolest
projects I've had the pleasure of
working on before that though if you can
contain your excitement I want to use
this video as a chance to tee things up
with a little bit of surrounding context
so to set the stage last video I
described quaternions a certain
four-dimensional number system that the
nineteenth-century versions of Wolverine
and the old man from home alone called
evil for how convoluted it seemed at the
time and perhaps you too are wondering
why on earth anyone would bother with
such an alien seeming number system well
one of the big reasons especially for
programmers is that they give a really
nice way for describing 3d orientation
which is not susceptible to the bugs and
edge cases of other methods I mean
they're interesting mathematically for a
lot of reasons but this application for
computer graphics and robotics and
virtual reality and anything involving
3d orientation is probably the biggest
use case for quaternions to take one
example a friend of mine who used to
work at Apple and a Mateus Jack
delighted and telling me about shipping
code to hundreds of millions of devices
that uses quaternions to track the
phone's model for how its oriented in
space that's right your phone almost
certainly has software running somewhere
inside of it that relies on quaternions
the thing is there are other ways to
think about computing rotations many of
which are way simpler to think about
than quaternions for example any of you
familiar with linear algebra will know
that 3x3 matrices can really nicely
describe 3d transformations and a common
way that many programmers think about
constructing a rotation matrix for a
desired orientation is to imagine
rotating an object around
easy to think about axes where the
relevant angles for these rotations are
commonly called Euler angles and this
mostly works but one big problem is that
it's vulnerable to something called
gimbal lock where when two of your axes
of rotation get lined up you lose a
degree of freedom and it can also cause
difficulties and ambiguities when trying
to interpolate between two separate
orientations
if you're curious for more of the
details there were many great sources
online for learning about oiler angles
and gimbal lock and I've left links in
the description to a few of them
not only do quaternions avoid issues
like gimbal lock they give a really
seamless way to interpolate between two
3-dimensional orientations one which
lacks the ambiguities of Euler angles
and which avoids the issues of numerical
precision and normalization that arise
in trying to interpolate between two
rotation matrices to warm up to the idea
of how multiplication and some higher
dimensional number system might be used
to compute rotations take a moment to
remember how it is that complex numbers
give a slick method for computing 2d
rotations specifically let's say you
have some point in two-dimensional space
like 4 1 and you want to know the new
coordinates you'd get if you rotate this
point 30 degrees around the origin
complex numbers give sort of a snazzy
way to do this you take the complex
number that's 30 degrees off the
horizontal with magnitude 1 cosine 30
degrees plus sine of 30 degrees times I
and then you just multiply this by your
point represent it as a complex number
the only rule you need to know to carry
out this computation is that I squared
equals negative 1 and then in what might
feel like a bit of black magic to those
first learning it carrying out this
product from that one simple rule gives
the coordinates of a new point the point
rotated 30 degrees from the original
using quaternions to describe 3d
rotations is simpler though the look and
feel is slightly different let's say you
want to rotate some angle about some
axis you first define that axis with a
unit vector which will write as having I
J and K components normalized so that
the sum of the squares of those
components is one similar to the case of
complex numbers you use the angle to
construct a quaternion by taking cosine
of that angle as
real part plus sine of that angle times
an imaginary part except this time the
imaginary part has three components the
coordinates of our axis of rotation well
actually you take half of the angle
which might feel totally arbitrary but
hopefully that's gonna make some sense
by the end of this whole experience now
let's say you have some 3d point which
we'll write with ijk components and you
want to know the coordinates that you'd
get when you rotate this point by your
specified angle around your specified
axis what you do is not just a single
quaternion product but a sort of quarter
neon sandwich where you multiply by Q
from the left and the inverse of Q from
the right if you know the rules for how
I J and K multiply amongst themselves
you can carry out these two products by
expanding everything out or more
realistically by having a computer do it
for you and in what might feel like a
bit of black magic this big computation
will return for you
the rotated version of the point our
goal is to break this down and visualize
what's happening with each of these two
products I'll review the method for
thinking about quaternion multiplication
described last video and explain why
half the angle is used and why you would
multiply from the right by the inverse
on the screen now and at the top of the
description you'll find a link to either
net / quaternions which has where been
set up the explorable video tutorial
where i explain what's going on with
this rotation computation it's it's just
really cool either did something awesome
here so at the very least just take a
couple minutes to go look at it but I'd
love it if you went through the full
experience
you